I asked on my blog who should be the
next CTO for other national government
cuz Barack Obama has said he's going to
have one I was surprised no one
suggested Al Gore uh after all you know
them fair joke is that he invented the
internet I think that someone like that
could be good but I also think that I
would look to perhaps one of the
founders of Google when I was at Davos
this last year I watched with amazement
as there was a discussion about the
environment with Al Gore and Bono at one
session where Al Gore was saying the way
to solve this is through carbon taxes
and prohibitions and regulation and then
I went to a session with the Google
foundation with Larry Larry and Sergey
as they're called and they saw the world
very differently they saw the role as
engineers rather than prohibitions they
were talking about inventions if we can
get the cost of electricity produced
well down below that produced by dirty
coal then we've changed the world and
they have so their answer was not taxes
and prohibitions their answer was
investment in invention and it was a
window to me on the engineers mind
engineers look for the problem and then
look for the solution the seduction of
the engineers view is that every problem
has a solution and life is not sometimes
so clean but I think that if we hire an
engineer who thinks like that not an Al
Gore in a politician god blessing but
instead someone like one of the founders
of Google to become the chief technology
officer of America and they start
looking at government as a platform and
they start looking at it as a means to
find and solve problems not to make
points I think it could bring a new DNA
into the bloodstream of American
government technology can and will open
up government the same way it's opening
up media and every other industry out
there it's lagging behind but it's going
to happen first and foremost because we
can talk to each other now second
because we can coalesce around causes I
think will become less of a two-party
country and more of a hundred thousand
cause country where from left and right
in anywhere we can gather around each
other third we demand transparency
online we're going to demand that kind
of transparency from government and when
we don't get it we're going to go find
it so we have projects like Congress
pedia and effort
to bring your marks to the public and in
the UK there are similar efforts going
on where we can use the public's
knowledge to say well what do we know
about these earmarks what do we know
about the activities of our congressmen
and if you don't expose it we will and
forth I think that where I hope we go to
with technology and government is not to
dwell always on the negative on the
gotcha moments on the scandals but
instead to dwell on the positive and
what we can actually do as a government
dell computer and starbucks just started
idea platforms based on salesforce
software so my Starbucks idea you can go
in and suggest you on a separate line
for brewed coffee because you're tired
of waiting for the guy what they will
accomplish in your order and then
starbucks comes in and they deal with
that they're going to start to implement
some ideas same with Dell why don't we
have that for government why don't we
have a forum where we can go in and make
suggestions and the good suggestions
will gain traction and will gain votes
and gain ideas and discussion and will
be improved and the government gets
involved in it that's what we should be
doing the bad ideas by the way will die
on the vine and I think that you have to
have some faith in the public you know
the Internet has made me a populist TV
maybe a populist when I realized that
good shows would rise in the ratings and
bad shows would fall it meant that the
public had taste there's a continuous
line here from that realization i had on
TV to the Internet itself where the more
choice we give people the better choices
they make and I realize that if you
don't inherently trust the people then
you don't believe in free markets you
don't believe in democracy you don't
believe in reformed religion you don't
leave it all these things so the
internet to me is about hearing from the
people and being able to trust the
people more so the Internet becomes kind
of a shadow government that will cross
over boundaries and cross over
ideologies and crossover party lines I'm
very hopeful about the impact of the
internet on government